c'est dans sa maison d'enfance et en
toute simplicité que sonia bompastor
reçoit une de ses admiratrices
comme chaque été la footballeuse
professionnelle profite de ces quelques
jours de vacances pour se ressourcer
chez ses parents à mer là où tout a
commencé pour elle j'ai toujours vécu à
mr jusqu'à mon adolescence c'est là où
j'ai eu tous mes copains et copines
d'école et c'est là où j'ai aussi
commencé le football à l'âge de 8 ans à
lui espère en mixité avec les garçons
depuis elle en a écumé des peuls aux
cinq saisons à lyon et deux à washington
vainqueur cette année du championnat de
france de la coupe de france et de la
champion's league
son palmarès suscite des vocations comme
celle de manon faut pas avoir de regrets
c'est travailler énormément à
l'entraînement et au match et tout
donner moi c'est toujours ce que j'ai
fait je pourrais y arriver peut-être
avec les conseils canal de nuit dans sa
chambre elle conserve toujours quelques
souvenirs de ces rencontres sportives
hors du commun notamment les jo de
londres
à titre personnel je suis assez déçu
parce que je pense qu'on avait vraiment
les moyens d'aller chercher une médaille
en tout cas c'était l'objectif qu'on
s'était fixé avant de partir là bas en
angleterre
sa carrière n'est pas terminée à 32 ans
elle rate a qu'une nouvelle saison comme
capitaine à l'ol je suis en train de
faire mes valises
parce que je repars demain sur nyon la
saison redémarre lundi j'ai rendez vous
à 10 heures pour la visite médicale et
pire quelques tests la valise bouclée et
le moral regonflé saunier entament ce
rennes la saison prochaine